قال الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرزلينسكي ان
قوات بلاده لا تزالت وسيطر على مدينه
بخموت في اقليم دونيت شرقي البلاد رغم ما
وصفها بمحاوله الروس وسعيهم لتدميرها
واضاف فازلين القوات بلاده تعمل على
التقليل من امكانيه القوات الروسيه في
اماكن وجودها بمنطقتي خيرسون
وظفروجيه والجنوب الاوكرانيه مؤكدا ان
حمايه حدود بلاده مع روسيا وبلا روسيا هي
اولويه ثابته لا هو انه يجب الاستعداد لكل
الصناعي واحد
كلود
في الشرق الاوكرانيه رغم محاولات المحتلين
وجهودهم المستميته لتدميرها وتحطيم
جدرانها في منطقتي زابروجيا وخرص وفي
الجنوب الاوكراني عموما تعمل قواتنا
تدريجيا على ضرب العدو وتقليل امكانياته
والخدمات اللوجستيه الخاصه به
بالنسبه
بالكامل من خلال تزويدنا بانظمه الدفاع
جويريه حديثه ودقيقه وباعداد كافيه حمايه
الحدود مع كل من روسيا او بلا روسيا هي
ايضا اولويات ثابته ونحن نستعد لجميع
سيناريوهات الدفاع الممكنه